welcome back everyone financial
stability is something
many are struggling with right now so
kendall tenney talks to an expert on
this subject let's check it out
lisa a lot of people right now are
receiving unemployment or and they're
not sure
and or they're not sure what the future
holds for them as far as employment is
concerned
there are some steps you say that they
can be taking right now
to make sure they're in good shape come
what may
okay the first one's what first one is
you've got to be honest with yourself
they're um the money at some point no
matter what the government decides with
a new package
they can't do that forever and you have
to be honest with yourself with where
you're at
and no one know your finances which
we've talked about before kendall
and understand how much time you have
before
unemployment runs out even if you can
extend it look forward to know is it 12
weeks is it 13 weeks
how long is this money going to last if
you're in an uncertain
unstable job position right now also be
willing to be honest with yourself
now is the time to start looking for
something new and now is the time if you
are
on unemployment to start looking for
when when you can start getting back to
work
where the new opportunities are some
people may hear that
and feel intimidated because they watch
the news or they read the papers
where unemployment is really high
and especially in las vegas what would
you say to them about that
it is high yes it is high and yes the
news is going to share a lot of
information to you
and and hopefully for me when i hear
that
i don't lose hope i go out and look at
where
people are hiring where are the
resources and i just
was looking at one statistic to follow
this guy's blog on linkedin
and instacart is hiring 300 000 people
right now mcdonald's is hiring 260
000 people right now amazon 175 000
people
and the list goes on and on so it may
not be the ideal job
i get that it may not be the ideal
career there's time for you to develop
yourself and get into in your career
path
but if you're looking for money and
you're looking for an opportunity to
work
they're out there let's get strategic
let's get you the help that you need to
find work so that the money doesn't run
out
and then what you're stuck and we don't
want that much better to start doing
that when there is still some resources
because then you're not in total panic
mode right
right absolutely panic is the worst
place i think
uh anyone watching this can relate to a
time in your life where you were
financially stressed
you're financially panicking and what i
teach my clients is one
get help you don't have to do this alone
i've shared this before get clarity of
where your financial situation
really is and let's look forward and
plan
and look at these different jobs that
are hiring even if they're temporary
places for you to land
they can help pay the bills while you
look for the next big
career for yourself always good
information where can people find you to
learn more
best places to go to my website
lisachastain.com
and i have information about how to get
into my world i also have a new online
class that you can take if you're hoping
to get control and clarity of your
finances now
terrific lisa thanks so much thank you